في ولاية مانيبور الهندية ،
ستجد منتزه Kuip alum Joe الوطني
، محمية الحياة البرية العائمة الوحيدة في العالم ،
تضم Cibola meow أكثر من 15
ميلًا مربعًا من العدسات الورقية الغنية بالتنوع البيولوجي
وتتضمن بحيرة
نقاشية أكبر بحيرة للمياه العذبة في شمال الهند
تشتهر الحديقة بها  بقع وحلقات من
الكتلة الحيوية التي تطفو على سطح
الأراضي الرطبة ، تزدهر النباتات العائمة المسماة
phoom d في المتنزه مما يخلق
منزلاً للإنسان والحيوان على حدٍ سواء
[موسيقى
] الفتى المهدد بالانقراض وهو نوع فرعي من
أيل قرن الوعل توجد فقط في
المنتزه  لقد أُطلق عليهم اسم الروح الملزمة
بين البشر والطبيعة ،
وكان يُعتقد أن فتى الأغنية على وشك
الانقراض في الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي ، ولكن بفضل
جهود الحفظ العدوانية ،
زادت أعدادهم بشكل مطرد إلى أكثر
من 200 لا يزال غير معروف نسبيًا
خارج المنطقة.
حقًا أحد جواهر الهند الخفية
[موسيقى]